Water
Earth
Fire
Air
you know I'm like I was talking some
cast to and of course I'm involved with the
IP and people reach out me people
have reached out to me on my platforms
from just random people all over
the world that want to be involved in
audition to you know close friends that
are in Hollywood that want audition and
it's like you'll see how involved I make
it in as a process continues but you
never know you know it's it's
Hollywood's filmmaking it's I know we're
at a time we were hopefully going to be able to cast this in a way it's gonna be very
inclusive to people of color and get it right and that would be always my
stance of trying to propel the story
forward but as far as you know specific
actors you never know until you know
these kids I don't know yes very strange
it's like it's Netflix we don't know
it's gonna be older guys playing younger
it's gonna be real stranger things we
can get really kids of that age doing
this epic adventure that plays
into a lot of things you know so we'll
see how it pans out I don't know I'm
excited I think was excited as anybody
else how it's gonna pan out but we'll see I
got my fingers crossed but Mike and
Bryan are helming it so I got all the
faith in the world those guys they
created the world they're so amazing as
artists and I respect them so much as
just guys and as men as well as
artists I can't wait to see what happens
and you'd be down to not necessarily
reprise your role but you would be down
to come back into the live-action
universe maybe you can play another
person. I'm an avatar family member for life. You know when the time's right
you know, you catch me. I might pop in
somewhere anywhere who knows people that
follow my career know me. I'm one of them
actors that can pop up anywhere at any
time
you know after 30 years of industry is
like Dante's show up anywhere.
Welcome back
everyone it's Charlie! This is going to be
my new avatar the last airbender Netflix
video we have Dante Bosco Zuko himself
talking about the new Netflix series
that they're currently working on right
now even though the virus is going on so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch
of cool Easter eggs and
behind-the-scenes stuff that's going on
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of
course I'll be doing episode videos and
bonus videos for the new Avatar The Last
Airbender series but there's a whole
bunch of cool updates
stuff that Dante Bosco talks about
during this so big shout-out to my dude
Dorian parks at Collider who scored this
awesome interview with Prince Zuko or
should we call him fire lord zuko I
guess it just depends on which part of
the timeline you're talking about so
we'll cover what's going on with the new
episodes that they're producing when
they're going to be casting and filming the
series with the new release date targets
going to be because of all the virus
delays and what's going on with the
original cast coming back and being
involved in the new show like Dante
Bosco is talking about during his clip
here so there's a lot to unpack here
I'll just number this as we go along to
stay organized you may have also seen
that new avatar the last airbender
trailer that was circulating a little
while ago there was an actual new
trailer for new avatar animation but it
isn't quite what you think it is this is
the clip this world is in trouble
we can't let this happen they need or
hold
this basically just meant to be a promo
for a new mobile game that's doing some
tie-in content with Avatar The Last
Airbender and Nickelodeon so it's not
like a new episode of the TV series or
anything like that
people saw it it started freaking out
like wait a minute this is brand new and
as for the new series Mike and Brian
also clarified what the story will cover
from the Avatar universe timeline and
what they're not going to be doing on
the series because there's been a ton of
reports about comic book stuff that
takes place after book 3 in the supposed
quote-unquote avatar season 4 plan that
some of the writers had before the big
live-action last airbender movie with
end night happened Dante Basco talks
about being involved with the series the
creative behind the scenes he says he's
actually heavily involved in the
creative side which I'm actually
surprised by Mike and Bryan did reveal
that they were trying to get him to
participate with the new series but they
didn't really specify what that meant
whether they would just try to get him
to cameo in the series or if he was
going to play a major character but now it
sounds like he's actually involved on a
creative level behind the scenes in the
development of the actual episodes he
also does say that he probably will pop
up as a character on the series although
he doesn't say which character
personally I'm hoping for someone like
uncle Iroh if he's going to have a major
role in the series or if he's only going to
be doing cameos then it's got to be a
cabbage man or foaming mouth guy if you
want to see him on the series more
though cabbage man does have way more
scenes just in terms of cameos I don't
really think that he'd be a good fit for
fire lord ozai
just because he's so soft-spoken like
his voice doesn't feel like an oozy kind
of voice Mark Hamill was actually the
voice of Ozai in the original series if
you didn't know that this defiant breath
will be your last Fire Lord Ozai
when I read it I thought this thing's
not going to last cause it's too smart it's
too intellectual it doesn't have the
flash bang wallop that seemed to be what
was popular at that time when dante
basco talks about being way more
involved behind the scenes with the
creative on the show i don't think that
he's going to be a full blown executive
producer or anything like that I don't
know he's going to get a producer credit
but he might wind up directing some of
the episodes because he is a filmmaker
himself he does have several of his own
side projects that he's produced over
the years and he doesn't even make his
own music on the side the last couple of
months he's also been blowing a big-time
because they just rereleased the
original series on net flow
so a lot of people are rediscovering the
series a lot of people are going back to
it
he even reads a lot of his avatar poems
that he writes on his live streams this
is actually a poem that he made about zu
Terra a while ago but then he talks
about the casting process I know there
are a ton of you that have messaged me
with questions about how the casting
process is going to work because of
Brian can yet SCO's Post from a couple
years ago where they said they would
have some form of open casting all that
open and casting calls stuff that won't
start till right before they get ready
to shoot the series and they need the
people that they would be casting it is
funny to hear Dante Basco talk about
other big Hollywood actors hitting him
up trying to get in the new series just
because so many people are fans of
Avatar and grew up with the series
they're going to him because he's like
Avatar man number one he also kind of
addresses the stranger things aspect of
the show which i think is a good
comparison to make the fact that the
show was about a group of relatively
young kids with Aang starting out as a
hundred and twelve year old man
chronologically but mentally and
biologically he's still 12 years old
super young in Katara Sokka and Zuko
aren't that much older
Zuko is the oldest team Aang member
biologically and he's only about 17
years old when the series picks up so
the big choice that Mike and Bryan have
to make for the show is how old to cast
the actors personally I don't care which
way they go with that as long as whoever
they get is good that's all that really
matters the only real issue with doing
it the stranger things way is that you
have to produce episodes a little
quicker than the traditional Netflix
series would so in terms of popularity
Avatar The Last Airbender could be
Netflix's new Game of Thrones I'm hoping
that makes them pick it up for multiple
seasons at the start so it's not really
a big issue getting season two out a
year after season 1 this is where the
actual amount of story that they're
covering on the new series is important
so a lot of you have read the Avatar The
Last Airbender comics like the promise
the search smoke and shadow and you know
that there's a ton of story that
explains what happens to all the
characters right out to the end of book
3 but because fans have been messaging
Mike and Bryan constantly about doing an
adult version of Team Aang in some kind
of new series they act
the answer saying that what they're
going to be doing is just a straight-up
adaptation of the original three book
series so they're just means they're not
going to be doing any of that comic book
story which is kind of a bummer but they
do still have some choices to make about
how to plot the episodes out will it
only be three seasons if they're only
going to be adapting the three books or
will it be six seasons and they'll just
split the story from each book into two
halves which in my opinion is probably
the better option they did imply a while
ago that they might do more animation in
the world of Avatar The Last Airbender
someday but they didn't say when that
might happen
or which avatar it would follow if we
get in news about that of course I'll do
a video but right now the timeline for
when the casting is going to start in
filming days is probably somewhere
between the end of this year and early
next year and then they would start
filming by spring of next year with a
possible release date between the end of
2021 or spring 2022 Netflix had
originally planned on releasing the
series in 2020 but that was way back in
2018 when they first announced it was in
development so if you really want some
new avatar story right now while you're
waiting for new episodes they're
currently writing an avatar kyoshi book
in multiple parts the first part has
already been released so you get a bunch
of her backstory Zach Tyler the voice of
Aang on the original series also just
did his first big avatar interview in a
long time this is what he looks like now
he's in his 20s that's how much time has
gone by
don't you feel old now he hasn't been
doing any big acting work or anything
like that since avatar he's mostly just
been doing normal human stuff like going
to college so even if all the avatar
actors don't show up in the new series
they probably will still be doing a lot
of side stuff at conventions and avatar
events in real life but everyone just
post all your reactions in the comments
below and let me know who do you want
Dante Basco to play on the new
live-action series everyone click here
for my other new video of Dante Basco
talking about Avatar The Last Airbender
and click here to learn all about the
new Batman TV show coming to HBO thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe I'll see you guys tonight!